The joe rogan experience.
How'd you get involved in this?
You started,
you said 24 years ago doing drug research on animals.
How did,
what,
what was,
what led you to want to go down this road?
So I was in,
I tell the story in the book and so I was in the air force back in the 80s,
like you mentioned about crack cocaine.
So I was in the air force over in England,
um,
86,
87,
88 and crack cocaine was a big deal in the United States as you point out.
And I grew up in the hood and Miami and Miami was a cocaine capital in the
United States.
And,
and so things that were happening in my community that were not good,
uh,
high unemployment crime,
all of these kinds of things,
I blame crack cocaine for that.
And so I thought that if I go to school and get a degree in order to study
drugs,
the effects of drugs on the brain,
I could solve the problems that face my community or problems that I thought
were in the community,
particularly those related to drugs.
And so I began studying drugs as an undergraduate and then went on to graduate
school to study drugs on the brains of animals and to try to figure out the
neuro biological mechanisms that were responsible for addiction.
So you just got
fascinated by this idea of fixing this,
this issue that you saw in your community and then you just fell into a rabbit
hole.
Yeah.
So when I started along my journey,
my path,
I actually got an education and you know,
so as James Baldwin said,
a,
you know,
the,
the paradox of education,
that's precisely it is as one begins to become educated,
conscious one begins to question.
It's the society in which he's being educated.
And that's what happened with me.
And so along the way I discovered things like the majority of people who use
these drugs are not addicted.
That was one thing I discovered.
I discovered that many of the things that we set about crack about crack cocaine
were just simply not true.
Like the cold crack baby myths.
And people said that when W.
Dot.
How generation B should be prepared to have,
uh,
an army of kids who couldn't learn because of being exposed to crack cocaine.
That just simply wasn't true when all the data came out beginning in the mid
1990s,
we realized that that simply wasn't true.
Uh,
other things that I learned that just simply wasn't true.
uh,
things like,
one hit of crack cocaine,
you're addicted.
Not True.
That crack cocaine was different from powder cocaine.
All of these things I discovered along the way,
but they weren't,
they weren't true.
And not only that,
I discovered that this wasn't new.
I went back to the early 19 hundreds and saw the same sorta hysteria,
mainly race hysteria surrounding drugs occurred even then.
And so I thought,
what's,
what's going on?
And then that helped me to be more critical about my issue.
Is there a difference in the,
the effect of crack cocaine,
physical effect,
and,
and cocaine and heroin?
So let's,
let's think about crack cocaine,
heroin rather vague about crack cocaine and powder cocaine.
Let's just think about the chemical structure.
The only difference between crack cocaine and powder cocaine is that the powder
cocaine has this thing called the hydrochloride salt attached to it.
That salt prevents it from being smoked.
Now you can dissolve the powder cocaine and,
and water and then shooting in your arm.
And so you have the effects of cocaine,
uh,
onset of the effects within seconds.
The same is true with crack cocaine.
The effects or onset of a sex effects are within seconds.
Now the biological activity of cocaine,
it's at the base,
not that,
so that hydrochloride portion on the,
uh,
on the cocaine powder,
on powder cocaine has no biological activity.
Whereas so,
so that means that crack and powder are the same drug.
They are exactly the same drug,
the same effect,
same drug.
Wow.
So it's indistinguishable to the user.
Indistinguishable.
Now why is it that they prepare it that way?
Like what's the benefit of preparing it is just
quicker.
A question.
So one of the things that you,
you might recall Richard Pryor back in the days when he got,
he burnt and he burned himself with smoking.
So he was freebasing and so he was removing that hydrochloride portion of the
salt off of,
off of the cocaine base so he could actually smoke it.
Now he was using ether,
which is highly flammable with crack cocaine,
you don't,
now,
you no longer need the ether.
You just mix it up with baking soda and water and the cocaine and you mix it up
and you get rid of that salt.
So eat there is no longer need it and is not as dangerous.
So that's one of the reasons that we have crack cocaine as a result of that.
And it also,
it made it so you could sell them in,
in unit doses to make the drug appear to be cheaper.
Because you also might recall in early 1980s,
1970s,
you had to buy cocaine powder and bulk and that made it more expensive.
Crack cocaine made it a lot more simple,
simple for people to buy it who didn't have,
uh,
the kind of,
expendable income that was required before the mid 1980.
So essentially they just brought it down to bite sized portions.
That's right.
Exactly.
What,
rather than selling this whole six pack or 12 pack,
now you can sell one item,
one can have one bottle.
I want to talk more about this,
but I should just clarify that Richard Pryor changed his story as he got older
and actually said that he tried to kill himself.
He lit himself on fire.
Apparently.
Um,
I'm a huge Richard Pryor fan and I know that that was originally what he had
said,
that he got burnt doing freebase but I think he changed his story later.
Um,
I actually worked with them a bunch of times right before he died.
It was a real honor.
He's a real special dude as far as standup comedians go.
Yeah.
Which you but that,
that um,
uh,
style of like free base was a thing that we know is associated with people that
were really,
really fucked up.
Yeah.
Like the guys doing coke.
Oh,
well,
you know,
he's probably gonna mess up his life.
He's freebasing.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
he's gone,
man.
He's based and he's a bass had.
Yup.
Right.
Base head was the thing before crack was bass heads.
Absolutely.
I described a couple of people in the book from my neighborhood who got into
freebase thing and exactly the same way you just talked about,
right?
Absolutely.
Um,
now everybody has this idea in their head that crime and that everything
escalated and the world changed when crack was introduced.
Is that a myth as well?
Yeah,
it's the myth that,
well,
let me clarify it because on the one hand,
so when crack hit the market,
it was first sort of,
uh,
talked about December,
1984 and the La Times,
the first time we heard a crack,
but it didn't become more widely known or available until maybe the mid 19,
may of 1985.
Now once crack cocaine hit the markets,
what happened was that people were fighting over various new markets and
whenever there are new illicit markets,
yeah,
you're going to get some violent activity until the market settles down.
That happened with any illicit market and that's certainly happened with crack
cocaine.
Now,
one of the things that people,
there are a number of things that people attribute to try to crack in terms of
crime and all of the sort of downfall of certain communities.
Unemployment.
They said that unemployment really rose as a result of crack cocaine being
around now 1982 the unemployment rate in this country was about 11% of white
folks and it was double that for black people.
That was before crack,
at least two,
three years before crack even hit the market.
Now doing the whole crack era,
unemployment has never been as high as 1982 that's number one.
People said things like,
uh,
people from my community did crack cocaine was responsible for these mothers.
These grandmothers now raising new generations of kids because their daughters
were strung out on crack and so now they have to take care of these kids.
That simply wasn't true.
It's certainly happened in,
in my community,
but it happened before crack cocaine was ever on the market.
Certainly happened in my family long before crack cocaine ever hit the market.
When we look at other communities,
like particularly immigrant community,
if you look at the Jewish community,
when they came over to eastern European Jews,
when they came over in the country,
the early 1,908 or 18 hundreds and so forth,
uh,
what you see is that you had a seamless sort of phenomenon going on and those
kind of communities,
what's his name,
urban,
how,
uh,
his great book land of our fathers,
a home of our fathers,
he kind of described all of these pathological behaviors that happened in that
community.
Many of those same behaviors were attributed to crack cocaine and black people
later,
but it's not it,
they were there long before crack cocaine was there,
but crack cocaine became the scapegoat.
That's a fascinating scapegoat
because I bought into it hook,
line and sinker.
I really thought that there was a difference between the 1980s in the 1990s as
far as like when crack was introduced,
boom,
it took off.
It was sort of something that was just always discussed as like common facts.
Yeah,
no,
I bought into a too and that's what drove me to pursue my education.
And the way I did.
But as a result of pursuing that education,
I discovered that it was not true.
So are these cultural myths the result of a politician like political campaigns,
we're trying to clean up the streets and they attributed to certain issues,
or is it,
is it something more widespread?
Is it the media just to we're running with a narrative.
What is it?
How'd it get started?
Well,
there were multiple sort of of factors and players involved.
So when we think about the politicians,
for example,
politicians,
if crack cocaine is the problem,
nevermind the fact that unemployment rate was out of control before crack
cocaine hit the mark,
hit the market,
unemployment was out of control.
A number of things were already uh,
problematic.
Now you have crack cocaine.
If you blame crack cocaine,
it's really easy to simply say,
we'll put more law enforcement,
we'll hire more.
Cops will put more efforts in controlling drugs.
A lot easier to say,
we'll lock people up for selling these drugs,
for using these drugs.
In the process.
What you do is you create jobs for a select group of people and then you don't
have to deal with the real issues,
the real issues of unemployment,
of deprivation.
All of these things you don't have to deal with.
There are far more complicated and so politicians are happy to buy in.
Now,
one of the things about crack cocaine is that when we think about the law that
punishes or punish crack cocaine a hundred times more harshly than powder
cocaine,
and the vast majority of people who got punished under these laws were black.
80,
85% of the people,
even though they don't make up the majority of the users.
So people will say things like,
well,
where those laws racist and the laws themselves weren't racist because the
congressional black caucus,
17 of the 21 members voted to uh,
for these laws,
for these laws that punish crack cocaine a hundred times more harshly.
But the point is,
is that everyone bought into it.
Parents bought into it because the parents,
for the parents,
what this meant is that you don't actually have to educate your kids about this.
You just say that they're bad and stay away from it.
No education required.
Um,
even sciences and treatment providers,
they all bought into it because you got a problem,
we're going to solve your problem.
So we are needed and we are valued all.
So you had all of these sort of constituencies from society benefiting from the
vilification or to escape goating of crack cocaine.
All of those things think came together nicely and then we think about the
wrappers.
They all came into the game too because it's like unconscious.
I'm going to say that this is a problem in my community and I care about my,
and this is the way that I can show it.
So everybody had a stake in this sort of.
Okay.
Wow.
That is absolutely fascinating.
You know,
one of the things that I've,
I've talked to quite a few people about when it comes to,
uh,
issues like real complex issues like drug addiction.
And violence and poverty is that once you feed it with any organism,
whether it's that organism is law enforcement or that organism is education,
whichever one you feed is the one that's going to grow.
And once you feed the law enforcement one and you look at this really complex
situation,
I think law enforcement is important,
but I think education is probably more important to avoid future law
enforcement.
Like the more I think the more education we have,
the the,
the more nuanced our ability to raise children is the more we understand that
we're all in this together,
the less you're gonna need law enforcement.
But when law enforcement becomes this machine that lobbies against the
legalization of certain drugs,
which when you start looking at the data,
there's only one reason to do that.
And the only reason is that you're trying to stay alive.
You're trying to grow,
you're an organism,
you're trying,
you're trying to eat the sugar that's trying to keep going.
So you're creating more jobs by putting people in jail.
It's essentially,
no one wants to look at it like this,
but it's a form of slavery.
Uh,
I think we in the house,
I live in the film,
Eugene Gr direct these film that,
I think that's the kind of analogy he was trying to draw in that film.
Absolutely.
So I,
I think we get it.
I think a number of people get that.
That's exactly what it is.
Okay.